christopher's in charlotte north
carolina hi christopher how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing better
than i deserve how can we help
oh yeah i was just going to ask you if
you were in my position what would you
do
i'm living at home i'm 27
i'm delivering pizzas i got about
9 800 in student loan debt and
i got about 29
000 in savings you have 9 800 in student
loan debt you have 29 000 in savings
and your your your only job is pizza
delivery
yeah i have a list in uber that
i've done from time to time to i used it
to help pay off my car
but i'm not doing that anymore now my
car's paid off i don't want to put all
the miles on it
so what are you going to do with your
life
i would really enjoy to go back to
school
with my degrees right now they're not
marketable for a good career
i'd love to go back to school and study
human resources
this program i got in mind and i just
been saving up for that
what's your degree in
psychology and political science
so what can't you do with a psychology
degree
um i feel like
i definitely could go down the route
human resources
i feel like eventually though uh to
get a better advantage i believe getting
a master's degree would hold a lot more
bull crap credibility absolute bull crap
you don't believe so
okay i run a 250 million dollar company
no one in my hr
department has a master's degree
no kidding and they're all getting too
by the way they're great and i don't
think any of them even have an hr degree
armando might our director of hr might i
don't know
my original director of hr did not i
know that um
no you you've got what it takes to get
in there you get your foot in the door
and if you want to go pick up some
classes
some one-off classes and audit some
classes just get some knowledge on hr
that would be advisable but i don't
think you need to go back and get a
four-year degree in hr plus a master's
in order to be able to be in hr i need
to get
the game man get in the game yeah it's
time to get in the game
i would pay off my student loans
yesterday and i'd move out the next day
yeah and go get a job in hr go get you
and go get your foot in the door
entry-level position recruiter or
something else and hr
get started and get with a company
that'll pick up some of your tuition and
go starts doing some study at night
instead of delivering pizzas with them
paying for it my sister's a recruiter
she
does remarkably well recruiter is my
bank she is
awesome she knows the business she knows
well but um she's got a bachelor's
degree
and she's smarter than me 10 times and
so man you got to get in the game dude
master's degree in human resources no
she's got a bachelor's degree bachelor's
yeah i'm just saying she's yeah she's a
rock star but she put the work in she
works real hard
and you got to get in the game brother
yeah yeah yeah yeah you you this is a um
you have a perceived blockage a blocker
here that's not real
right it's not a real blocker
christopher so uh but get your foot in
the door and
get started up hang on i'm gonna give
you a copy of ken coleman's book the
proximity principle
and if i were you i would get started
tomorrow tomorrow all of that
i pay off my student loan today i'd make
plans to move out you got plenty of cash
you're in a good shape
go get you you know you can work the
part-time gigs if you have to pay bills
for a little while
until you land the job but i would go
get an hr position
somewhere that you'd love working and
again use kins of material king coleman
can help you land that job
kencoleman.com there's all kinds of get
the interview get the resume stuff right
all of it's free and downloadable and
i'm going to give you his book so
we've given you everything that he's got
and and he can help you land that for
sure
but um you know so christopher if if you
hear what just happened is dave ramsey
just called your bluff
he just called his bluff man and so now
he's taking all the excuses off the
table
all of the well you know i'm just stuck
my degrees nope it's over dude
here's the book here's the resources
here's the high five go get them
and it i'll tell dave his hr department
here is extraordinary
our hr department they're excellent they
are excellent at what they do they are
there maybe 17 of my master's degrees i
don't know i really don't
but they were not hired for master's
degrees and they were not kept from
doing something because of a master's
group
i mean i can i cannot think of anybody
over there that even has an
hr degree much less a master's degree
they might
want to might but um but uh
i mean you know we're again
hr is about taking care of the team love
people
love loving the team and hiring the team
right
hanging on it's recruiting and taking
care and loving the team and
and you know a psychology degree i'll
assist you in that a big heart will
assist you in that
caring about people assist you in that
and then god help you somewhere along
the way you're going to learn something
about the law as well
but um but the the rest of it is you
know
there's no there's no technique that
they're going to teach you in a master's
degree that allows you to
be unless you want to work in a cold
toxic corporate environment then you
might need a master's degree but i don't
think that's going to be your goal
you need to get jobs where you go in and
look at people here's another thing
christopher can do
is when he delivers pizzas in the
evenings
as he's grinding through trying to get
some get his foot in the door in another
position
he can take those 30 second those
one-minute exchanges
and learn how to read somebody learn how
to be kind to somebody learn how to make
somebody's day
when i worked at burger king at the
front register i learned
at a young age it takes about 10 seconds
to make somebody's day or to ruin it
right and that lesson as a 16 year old
kid has
has ridden with me all the way through
is treat people with dignity get to know
somebody
that fast um honor somebody give them
what they need and step back those kind
of
little personal skills those investments
and people loving
every person you come in contact with
that's gonna make you a great hr person
down the road
beyond a whole other program man six
four years